on behalf of ourselves and our team we
are going to place a statement as a team
today
nba players are sending a message after
a national
outcry it all started after the
milwaukee bucks announced they would be
sitting out their scheduled playoff game
wednesday night
we are expected to play at a high level
get maximum
effort and hold each other accountable
we hold ourselves to that standard
and in this moment we are demanding the
same from lawmakers and law enforcement
we are calling for justice for jacob
blake and demand the officers be held
accountable
the wisconsin-based team is reacting to
police shooting 29-year-old jacob blake
in kenosha witnesses said blake was
attempting to break up a
fight when police arrived at the scene
sunday night blake was shot by a police
officer
seven times other players from the
league have taken to social media to
express
their outrage lebron james tweeted
this man we demand change sick of it
denver nuggets player jamal murray said
we demand
justice wnba players are also making
their voices heard
after speaking with representatives from
teams playing tonight
as well as our wnbpa leadership the
consensus
is to not play in tonight's slate of
games atlanta dreams player elizabeth
williams announced the entire league
would not be participating in games on
wednesday night
we stand in solidarity with our brothers
in the nba
and will continue this conversation with
our brothers and sisters across all
leagues and look to take collective
action
in a chilling moment players from the
washington mystics were seen in t-shirts
that spelled out jacob blake's name
the back of the shirts featured images
of bullet holes
wednesday just so happens to coincide
with the anniversary of a pivotal
intersection of sports and activism
it's exactly four years after former nfl
player colin kaepernick protested during
the national anthem for the first time
i think the biggest thing now is to kind
of
as a black man as a former player and
sports broadcasters have even taken to
showing
their support commentator kenny smith
opened up about the nba strike
during a taping of inside the nba which
he concluded by walking off the set
i think it's best for me to support the
players
and just not be here tonight